hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of top 5 Skyrim mods of the week
I am cam and who is this guy oh it's
said the handsomest one he's with uh
with the great hair oh yeah you guys
love his hair that's true
did I tell you sir I got about 20
messages of people telling me that like
your hair is such passing it on to you I
got a bunch that they like your hair oh
really yeah thanks you guys do know
which of us is which right hey there may
not be very much of it but what's there
is fantastic it's solid build hair that
is okay and well this week is a special
one sir it is it's video game history
month on gains ball calm so it's our
turn at Skyrim mods of the week to kind
of embrace this so we're gonna bring you
some mods with a difference so let's get
to modern number one and here we are set
month number one have you ever heard
it's called maro whined maro I know no
Muro went boo rewind my favorite kind of
rides yes so we're actually gonna be
playing the Elder Scrolls 3 morrowind as
modern number one no serve I have a
confession all right I've never blade
more Owen I have a confession what's
that neither of I oh this is gonna be
gold solid gold well so let's load up
our autosave and listen that music it's
like it's like the Oblivion music but I
know no it's the Skyrim music but
simpler is it duh duh duh so this oh god
attacked by something you don't want to
kill already okay man look at those
graphics oh god I think we might have
marrow match right at the beginning no
not even a bit okay so cam I noticed
that we have ah I think it's had more
things everything in Morrowind and ass
or what have you got some home to meet
around meet apply Heron meet tick III
did I just ate it
Oh God we didn't dispose of the corpse
cam I'm sorry sorry yeah this is high
tide alert well their murder I love this
button in this game what the hell is
that about where does it go so we have
actually modded morrowind with one
enormous 1.7 gig mod and it's called the
morrowind sound and graphics overhaul
now I know
is going to be a bit silly considering
camp neither cam or I have actually
played morrowind yeah I don't know
exactly what we're looking for I think
we have somehow broken the the distance
loading though yes he can see a bit
bizarre but once you get to a place my
word does it look
what's it slowly then holy jesus also
those animations check a mat yeah so
you've got no magic yet we are rich
though 10021 gold which money it makes
me have totally just hack the balls off
oh we've also got oh I think I've used
my ward power yeah Oh accidentally so
I'm let's try Thunder fist
oh that work did that work
oh yeah well I just used it well yeah so
go go I'm good it looks like the
landscapes bleeding yeah it does a
little bit Oh so we've definitely broken
something there go go to go to there go
to this place cedrus more morrowind
doesn't come with fast travel amazing
okay brilliant you can use silt Striders
or mages guild guides for travel in
between cities here we are sad sad drift
more oh are we real weird-looking or
what it what the hell i'm looking for a
place to buy better weapons we just got
this starry iron sword thing that looks
like it's me yes
sell barter okay give me oh let's get
the strongest stuff let's get a long
ball for one all right did that work
it's on the table now hip hip i see
total cost total cost yes you've added
it to your what I think you're bartering
and you're doing it real bad offer I
think it worked I mean I think she she
gave you the cost and you were like what
no let me give more but you are on my
dodgy I muted you seen this bow this is
a quality bow oh yeah I definitely spent
some more money let's get some some
arrows as well there hundred six whoa
you're only about to spend 106 gold on
this cam that's fine you need to up we
go in gabon arrows you are basically
making this woman's day no stronger
my chump and this looks powerful
daikatana chop well I got that sword
yeah look at it look at this action oh
that and that all right what about the
get some armor hey where'd you get that
you gotta want some we had predator face
as well I think Steel's probably smart
okay so uh you got a nice buy right and
left stuff Wow
I'm liking this minigame already look at
this I'm not sure I'm putting on the
right order now that's definitely the
right old helmet next and then finally
putting on the curious real chess play
Boosh oh wow
look at your man yeah we have come a
long way gay runs off look at him
running fear it's a healthy movement now
amazing pretty oh there you go
yeah and there when you in town and
we're over encumbered with cash
uh Oh barter there we go ah okay we're
gonna be summer the restore health oh
she's got different looking arrows did
she narrows that maybe don't suck oh we
got a weight limit that we're with
teasingly yeah yeah I think so we got
like 300 weight limit throwing knives
I'm totally gonna take some of those min
or 50 die ah it's getting a lot of blood
she's got a load of regular health yes
he's almost he's almost gone those are
those stabbing ones and real good search
him steal everything he owns tick oh and
let if there if it's all decent a short
sword and some nice leather let's take
it can I get should sell it yeah you
want some of that too huh now she cool
she learned her lesson yeah oh no she
didn't
no I didn't nothing but death for you
lady oh you're gonna regret that
oh she got spells died already then she
go said hey yeah you're murdering let
the best of them like I take a warrant
facing war axe now any business said
yeah I definitely would never have had a
computer powerful enough to ever run
this I wasn't PC in gaming at all in
this kill me I was I just was also poor
he'll never get past our tower shields
yes sir we showed him are you still
alive all right that's a really bent
arrow what are we left handers I guess I
hit him oh no I think I just missed him
we got on that time yeah oh man I live
out of the sky love this bow and arrow
this is amazing
go good feeling about oh my god this guy
doesn't he's immune to weapons he's a
means of weapons oh dear it's not good
yeah
throwing knives did nothing hold on to
those we'll need them let's run away
from this guy I just hope that
everything we meet in here isn't also an
invulnerable dude now that doesn't look
like a navona body i got another guess
right yeah okay what let's say well they
don't do a great deal
no but they certainly slowed her down a
tiny tiny bit jeez it's cheesy all right
let's get the real lighting engine in
here yeah yeah that what a fight Oh
Oh friends colleagues that's all right
they know what's up you hurry up it's oh
this go Oh sad these guys are
invulnerable to weapons what are they do
you think I don't know if your weapon is
maybe you like exhausted or something ah
I hate that guy
what are they hit this guy no these guys
pretty strong I love the noise very
chest see what it is
what do we get I love the chest opening
explosion nice that's pretty cool it did
say was trapped say the book of Daedra
wooden stuff or if the wooden stances I
think yes these guys in a good new SEM
weapon has no effect crud I thought
would would be their downfall me to any
weakness I said this has been M
educational coming to morrowind when you
say I would say that I have learned many
things I would I would love to actually
explore some more yes the quirks is so
fun to see where the series has come
from with how much has changed anyway I
think we should have continued video
game History Month with our next mod sab
it's time for number two and this week
it's oblivion it kind of always said it
was before
but it's not it's not mod number two
number two I did not see this one coming
oh this one gonna be put on trial you I
did not see the second game being a
second one yeah no I by that I mean of
the fourth year the fourth game we know
what we mean it's fine it's fine the
second game the worst showcase is day
but important thing is I wasn't just
gonna load up a save file because I
wanted to play some of this music
because it just brings back so many
memories
so you know how we didn't play morrowind
seb yes not confession to make every
single oblivion i oblivion get into
oblivion yes so did I Wow so this looks
different from how I remember well
that's cause I've modded it up the wazoo
cam so as I'm sure you've already
noticed I've put any mb on here quite
clearly great letter field going on
there tell whether the depth of field
its it suddenly got a little smoky yeah
that's fine
so there the depth of field is quite
nice yeah I've also by the way that's
called a tweaked env tweet here beep oh
god mud crab
look at that efficient if nothing else
you only have meat I remember these
menus yeah you do
I've also put on the HUD status bars
which either or that you've noticed at
the bottom down there yeah I have it's
given it more of a Skyrim look when you
download this mod you thought oh you've
got a bunch of different options too as
for the kind of look you wanted to go
for because I've put the compass at the
top and you've got all of the different
things at the bottom that this is more
of the Skyrim look so it really is that
was that
particular choice here's our guy let's
take off that dumb hood doesn't really
look much like Kevin van Nora but my god
he is pretty eyelashes I tell you why he
has pretty high that I know is that
because we have put the Oblivion
character overhaul version two on he
looks less melted than them yeah artists
used to yeah they were a little bit sort
of wax work II weren't they they were
it's really all we've got in terms of
weather at weather don't it's not what I
meant I meant clothes and I tried to see
leather and I failed so the reason it
probably looks so nice and lush and
everything is because we've also put
natural environments mod on as well and
it looks quite nice I'm trying to
remember back to Mike because I played
oblivion on the 360 not on PC
yeah so everything was obviously fixed
yeah and I know that you have at least
graphical options on this but this does
definitely look better
oh really does like the depth of field
is a big part of that - she works with
the bit that the field almost works
better than saw the ones in Skyrim yeah
no this steps that feels dude real real
nice like it's fragile
it just hides all the ugliness yeah I
know that you get with faraway stuff but
well Matt so let's have a look at this
lady's face go inside and talk to Thomas
it's not that melty no it's much better
let's find some rumors say do it do it
they charged me five gold for lettering
littering Wow oblivion leveled with your
character yes so as you got through the
game you would be able to buy more
impressive stuff at the moment if we
could go into any shop in the whole of
oblivion and we would never find good
equipment the March rider sells and
repairs weapons and armor
the lighting is much better ladies so
much better yeah on her face and
everything okay good new Seb
we're what once again we are rich as all
hell but I should have just pushed us
over the a million mark so that's good
let's try this again shall we just doing
some of my work
what it does four million seven that we
have too much money
I know give me your fine captain Gordian
saber please that looks real nice
prepare repair Jimmy this seven oh dude
good thing it what's the most tedious
thing in the world
look at that
yeah take that that's an impervious
tomato I have actually put on a another
mod which was a better-looking Armour so
technically our armor should be looking
a little bit better than old vanilla
armor overlook oh god Sam
yeah really looks much better all those
eyelashes can't get over so apparently
it doesn't increase the resolution but
it just increases the quality okay I'm
just better textures yeah apparently so
it improves the way it interacts with
the light question he says so the actual
resolution itself is the same what type
of character did you play as you put
oblivion serve I believe I played a Red
Guard in my character okay um was your
play style my play style changed so I
played through once and got to level
eight stopped and played again I got
sick of trying to do like a sneaky thief
and the focus on magic in the end I
decided to re-roll as a full-blooded
warrior I just go in access blazing had
a great time I see I was always this
kind of character to be honest I was a
big fan of the bow and arrow
I'm usually wet for light armor I've
still got my archery skills apparently
where would you like to go traveler
ahead we have a weird statue to our
right we have a door and to our left we
have another weird statue go south
that's the way we came said okay we're
going east
yeah era door yet do it you cannot get
the door sir travel door oh it's [__]
Eve I mean another imp
guy get him can't you cannot get the IMP
I think that one was named Stacey oh
good that stars are right ah look at
look at this god I want to go back and
play oblivion again with EMP I know how
much nicer it is after you gonna see
with you can be I thank you baby he's I
want to play with anybody else I was
just thinking said this is can like
oblivion is like an old friend yeah
except one that's got better looking
better look amazing time get this yeah
it's so gorgeous
I've got softer features yeah smoother
and their lighting is babish necessity
and lighting is better too yeah great
oh look at that oh that is so nice it's
good to be back oblivion tell you what
cam I think I agree that I think the end
being this is nicer than the Skyrim ENB
yeah it's really good it just seems
solid it's really really solid it's a
cat person
oh gosh buy some stuff have a look
around nothing be the bet battle axe of
hatred that's exactly how I feel about
everything gimme gimme gimme
I see that is the exact thing that we
need only emotion I know if we could
take one thing Bolivian into Skyrim for
Kevin Bernard back it's got to be the
battle axe of hatred not agree more so
oh so much hatred such grace I know
right thanks such great
hateful hating Jace
Stonewall shields we yeah - lies him
what do you sell she's just full of
hatred mmm
what'd you say why I don't know maybe it
might just bounce offer because of the
hatred let's find out stop
maskull e quickly what do you do she was
just a rest
yes okay let me just a dude on someone
there you go oh no what - Jo I didn't
mean to go to jail you are such a such a
bad person me to do that it is hard so
don't screw this up balls well hey you
know what I love this app is serve my
time be aware of my battle axe of hatred
how my but Lex hates you and a carrier
what do you care axis way better than
their silly sledgehammers no you die
hedge wizard alright we did real good
there we sure did
well said I think it's been a lovely
return to oblivion
it's been great coming back just the Sun
breaks through the clouds I know here by
the lighthouse in a anvil yeah I wish
yeah I really wish I get a play like
this at the first time it really hammers
home for me how much they progressed
from morale into oblivion yeah the
difference is night and day and look at
that night and now rain there a day now
right but you know what is missing an
oblivion Seb that we do have in Skyrim
what is that chickens chickens there are
no chickens in a blue certainly on so
let's go find some oh man said we're
back in Skyrim well there's all the
graphics that I remember haha oh jeez
look at all those graphics it really
looks great it does is it great but at
the same time it reminds me that you
know the step from Morel into oblivion
was much bigger much bigger leap than
the Oblivion Skyrim though oblivion
Skyrim still very pretty I think it's
mostly pronounced in the character
models and the armor and stuff like you
haven't bundled looks well he always
looks like he's looking spectacular guy
really at some point I think we're gonna
have to make him the axe of hatred are
we gonna oh I think we still next week
yeah let's making the acts of hatred
next week we will make or if somebody
wants to make a mod acts of hatred yeah
we will get that done make it the most
hateful acts you can possibly imagine
and we will absolutely wield that for a
while cuz man that should be Kevin's
weapon of choice I've never trusted this
guy or his horse no what's this what's
his deal hey uh no I don't want you
gonna give you an a right sir right to
the sky but your horse can take you
there
alright chickens said I'm gonna light
the fuse on this particular collection
of 100 chickens out there they are
alright well they were are they all
right here light one is the chickens to
blow okay okay here we go
oh wait wait that yeah there you
chicken how we're off not impervious to
fire as previously described very
flowing with the torch before Seb I
don't think we have he's handling a well
it's good to see that the torch still
burning yeah yeah yeah unaffected by the
the rush of the air is he full quality
torches to be found in Skyrim yep good
boats look at that press up the finish
that is so Kevin that is so Kevin well
said that was a nostalgia rific trip
down memory lane
yeah to oblivion and I was fun to
finally play morrowind a bit yeah well
my heartstrings feel thoroughly tugged
good I don't my curiosity piqued for
finally playing morally yeah I notice I
was just it was nice to see Livi looking
his best you know the old girl still
does some life in ER which is great I
really wish that mod for a morrowind
hadn't broken yeah distance sorting I
really sorry like if you love more when
to play the loads and then to see us
ruin it with that miss installing of
that graphics thing a dude polish yes
but but but you won't did ya are wind do
let us let us know tell us your favorite
moments best way to do that is to tweet
at either me yourself at camp France
robbed at Ready Steady Go and when the
hashtag GS Skyrim yes and if like us you
played loads of oblivion and wants to
share your best memories I'd love to
hear him yeah I mean I was just trying
to remember my favorite places when we
were there and it'd be great to get some
some little memories from you folks too
so I bet if we if we went back and
played oblivion for more than about
three or four minutes we would probably
be like I remember this I remember this
oh yeah I've been was great place to
lately but you know that was in the past
camp and we've played it and I know it
maybe it needs to stay in the past from
but if you have still got to play
oblivion and you really want to go check
it out you should definitely try some of
those mods that we were to showcase
mm-hmm the tweaked EMB alone Wow
now of course this has been a departure
from the usual top 5 scary mods week
format it'll be back as normal next week
and that will also be burned you'll have
the votes and the questions and comments
and all that good stuff so make sure you
get in touch with us you want appear in
that show and but yeah I hope you've
enjoyed this special edition of the show
yeah for games History Month we're
having here on GameSpot yeah and um yeah
we can't wait for next week to get back
into Skyrim with Kevin Bernard so we
will see you
you